right
so hi everyone welcome to my talk today
i am thrilled to be able to virtually
join you and to have this opportunity to
present my research before you the title
of my today's talk
is designing for voice access autonomy
and justification questions in designing
computing technologies with marginalized
communities
before starting my talk here is a brief
introduction of myself
my name is said ishta khan i'm an
assistant professor at the department of
computer science at the university of
toronto
i earned my phd at cornell university in
and masters of 2014 and i'm a
bangladeshi citizen i was born and
raised in bangladesh
and before coming to north america i did
my bachelor and master's in computer
science from bangladesh university of
engineering and technology
so now i'd like to share with you the
background of my research
i grew up in bangladesh in 1990s so
while growing up i found
many computing technologies were coming
into the country desktop computers
mobile phones style of internet and all
others
and this continued even in early 2000s
when we saw technologies like
broadband internet smartphones tablet
computers smart watches
social media sharing economy
applications they kept coming to the
country
and saw that this technologies were
bringing several notable changes to the
lives of the local people in bangladesh
i kept asking to myself this question if
those changes were actually desired by
the local communities
or they were imposed on them more often
than not i found the computer
technologies were not addressing the
main challenges that the local people
had in their lives
so when i grew up i set my goal to
understand the needs
of these hundreds of populations and
work with them to improve the quality of
their life
with this in mind i developed the first
ever human computer interaction research
group in bangladesh in 2009
with some bright undergraduate students
in bangladesh university of engineering
and technology
in the last 12 years with this group and
other collaborators
i have started different marginalized
communities in bangladesh india pakistan
and canada
and i documented their problems and
design technologies with them
these communities include ready-made
garments workers taxi drivers
ethical slum dwellers mobile phone
repairers and victims of signal
harassment
among others while conducting my
research with these communities
first they try to understand their
challenges in these people's life by
starting their culture politics economy
and history
then i built computing technologies with
them that are
accessible inclusive robust and lovers
so my research methodology is actually a
combination of ethnography and computing
with these research methods i try to
address the central theme of my research
which is voice
so let me first explain to you what i
mean by voice and why is voice important
for marginalized communities to answer
these questions
let us think about the world that we
live in we often call this world the
world of data and information
for many of us we get information when
we open a newspaper
or turn on television radio or switch to
social media
all of these sources can be thought as
platforms of voice
where we learn about the stories and
opinions of various communities
these and other similar platforms are
also often used for harvesting data and
we the computer scientists
often use those data for developing
computational models
however how many of us have ever thought
that these platforms do not represent
the actual data information opinions and
parts of various materialized groups
for example it is almost impossible to
find the thoughts of millions of
illiterate people on these platforms
because they either do not read and
write or they do not use the digital
technologies
similarly we won't hear the voice of
millions of victims of sexual harassment
on these platforms because talking about
sex is often stigmatized in many
communities
then millions of factory workers around
the world don't feel safe to share their
thoughts because
the fear of losing their jobs similarly
millions of refugees do not really
participate on these platforms because
their identities are not secure and
protected
there's our digital platforms and other
methods of collecting data
led the representation of this and many
such marginalized groups
or in other words as i say we lack their
voice in our computing systems
now i define voice as a comprehensive
social technical process
for these communities for obtaining
freedom this voice is not only a final
product for me
but also the entire process that gives a
community the necessary freedom
to stand for their concerns my research
tries to understand where when and how
this process of voice is hampered
stopped and people are silenced and how
we can design socio-technical
arrangement with the communities to
overcome these challenges
this objective frequently leads me to
various relevant research questions
related to voice for example how can
technology be accessible to all
how can we achieve social freedom over
technology
how can we make an infrastructure
inclusive and sustainable
or how can we make people's voice heard
and these are just only a few of the
questions that i explore
so i have been addressing these
questions of access autonomy and
justification in my research for the
last 12 years
in today's talk i'll briefly describe my
projects on access and autonomy
and then focus on more recent projects
on justification
so when i started talking about voice
and thinking about voice the first
thought that i had in my mind was that
one in every five people in the world
cannot read and write
and there are many others who are
similarly right and there are
many who are digitally illiterate these
and other major barriers
this is one of the major barriers for
them to access the digital platforms and
share their parts
i looked into the existing research on
making computing technologies accessible
to low-retarded populations
and i found that scholars had made great
efforts by making the interfaces more
accessible
to the low-literate users by adding
graphics and audio interfaces
while each of this effort made some
success they all failed after a certain
limit because those interfaces demanded
the low literate user to remember
graphics or audio close which was not
possible for them after a certain limit
i realized that most efforts in making
the computing interfaces
was either depending on the user
cognitive ability or the ability of the
interface to help the user's cognition
however my living experience in
bangladesh told me that
the use of mobile phone is often shared
in that part of the world and targeting
a single user for the use of technology
might not be appropriate for the local
communities
having this in my mind i conducted a six
month long ethnography with a group of
illiterate ritual drivers
in a garage in kamran get your area in
dhaka bangladesh in 2012.
these detail drivers are illiterate but
they all were using mobile phones
so in this ethnography my objective was
to learn how they were able to use their
phones
and what are the challenges they might
have in using this computing device
when i found that the rickshaw drivers
would take help from their garage owner
who was a literary person
and was willing to help the drivers in
using their phones
soon i also found that some other such
literal members
in their communities were helping these
illiterate picture drivers
this model of help matched well with the
gift-giving theories in the classical
anthropology
especially with the work of martial moss
but there are challenges too
from our field work we also learned that
the illiterate drivers would
struggle to use this gift when the
helping hand were not around them for
example at night when they were at home
with their families and when they were
away from their work
from their garage in the daytime
to address that problem based on the
gift giving theory of martial mosques
and the lessons that we got from our
field work i co-designed a mobile phone
application for the rickshaw drivers
that
allow them to take help from their
garage owner remotely
we used rough matching algorithm to find
the most suitable metals and to
distribute the load of helping
the implementation was based on text
messages as the use of internet wasn't
common within that community and because
we wanted to keep the cost
low we deployed the prototype with 12
participants for six weeks and the pilot
and then with 60 participants for six
months as a longitudinal study
in both cases we found that the users
found even comfort in using our system
and it contributed to making their
community warm
stronger we reflected on our work on
access in this project and took
a few important lessons for the
marginalized groups in the global south
number one modern computing design is
often built on western assumptions
which are not applicable in places
outside the western world
this lesson is aligned with the theory
of postcolonial computing by lilly irani
davita phillip and their colleagues
and number two when we look at a problem
from a western perspective
we often means the local resources like
community bonds
that can be very important and essential
design resources for people in the
global south
this lesson is aligned with the theory
of asset-based design by kentaro toyama
nihakumar and their colleagues
in summary any design effort for helping
access to
computing should be rooted in the local
social context
however only access is not enough while
it is important to make technologies
accessible for all
it never ensures the voice of
marginalized builds over computing
platforms
we need something more many people have
technical access to computing systems
and they can read and write
but they are not free to express their
thoughts despite having technical access
to computing their voice is settled by
the society
this is why the next important step
toward voice is freedom
or economy to explore the challenge with
autonomy
i turn to the problem of sexual
harassment in bangladesh
like most other countries in the world
sexual harassment is a serious problem
in bangladesh
thousands of incidents of sexual
harassment are reported each year to the
buddhists
however as the focal scientists found
most incidents of sexual harassment
remain unreported officially women do
not want to talk about this
because this topic is stigmatized in the
community many of these women are rich
and
educated they have access to modern
computing technologies and they know how
to complain over social media
however they often remain silent because
of the overarching social pressure
i wanted to find the root of the silence
with a group of female researchers in
bangladesh
our team spent more than one year to
conduct anonymous surveys interviews and
focus group discussion with the women
who suffered from sexual harassment
liberal participants told us that almost
all the women in bangladesh have
experiences of direct or indirect sexual
harassment
but very few of them actually talk about
it and it was
evident even in our data collection
process
we could only conduct 11 interviews in
the whole one year even after
advertising widely
some women registered for the interview
and then cancelled the appointment
some came but then decided not to talk
some busted into tears in the middle of
the interview and left
some completed the interview and then
called us and asked us to delete the
interview
it was evident to our research team that
the silence around sexual harassment was
not easy for them to break
the pew introduced an fgd is that we
could finally completely give us some
important insights into this problem for
example we could learn that
the women wanted to help at the spot
they wanted to quickly reach out to
their friends and families and the
victims felt better when they would
share their stories with others
however the main problem that we found
through our study was silence
total stigma fear shame and pain was
silencing them
in response we developed a mobile phone
application
that would allow women to report a
sexual harassment ask for help at the
sport
and instantly reach out to their friends
and families
we also developed a website where women
could report the
incidents that the experience are
observed we were visualizing the report
over a live map of the city
they would also share their cars in the
form of a blog anonymously
we would share the reports and blogs
over a facebook page to create more
awareness
and invite dialogue we call this system
protibaly
a band award that means one who protests
we launched the system publicly in 2013.
soon after the launching we started to
get thousands of reports each day where
women anonymously reported various kinds
of harassment from inappropriate pathway
category from horrible abuse to serious
forms of physical torture
this project was highlighted in many
national international news media
outlets
including the bbc and the team
scientists however at the same time we
also observed that
the anonymous reports were attacked by
many men and women on social media
its people started to blame the victims
for example the screenshot here shows an
anonymous report by a woman
who was catcalled on the speech as she
did not cover her head she felt abused
and reported about that unbreakably
however when the anonymous report was
published many men and women
started to blame the victims saying she
was asking for it because she wasn't
covering her head
similar incidents started to happen
frequently over prudibadi and we saw a
decline in reporting
at one point the rate of reporting went
down so low that we decided to close the
system
this was an important lesson for me on
how the voice of the marginalized groups
like women is silenced by the society
i further noticed that the mechanism of
this silence is was ethics
for example in this case the crowd used
a version of islamic ethics to silence
the victim
similarly in some other cases i saw
people were using western neoliberal
feminist ethics to blame women who chose
the life of a homemaker
i started asking these questions who
determines what is right and what is
wrong over
a computing platform how ethics can be
used as a tool for silencing
marginalized groups
and how can we extend them the values of
the marginalized communities by
establishing their ethics in and over
computational platforms
it went and allowed me to explore the
growing scholarship within computer
science around
ethics and computing more specifically
ethics in ai
i found that the scholars in the western
world have been criticizing the modern
computer science and its various
applications
for either purposefully supporting or
for making the way for various
analytical activities let us explore
some of these concerns
among various concerns of unethical use
of computing systems privacy breaching
is the leading concern
video ci algorithms and other computing
applications are found to be capturing
sensitive private information of the
users and using them
to gain profit even worse in many cases
such
data are used to manipulate people's
political orientation
among many social as the world's book
the age of surveillance capitalism
explains this problem in details and
shows how private data of inverses
as the fuel of data-driven capitalism
another important concern that has been
voiced by scholars
in is the biases and computing systems
especially in the data-driven systems
the scholars like luha benjamin and
virginia evans have explained
how various practices around data
reflect the historical biases
in the society and hence data-driven
systems are often biased against the
marginalized groups
if we look deeper into these ethical
concerns
that have been voiced by the scholars we
see how they are rooted in some ethical
standards that are commonly accepted in
the west many of these concerns are
underpinned by the
fate in secularism democracy nationalism
liberalism and free market economy for
example
as a result the associated scholarship
has been successful in determining
problems with racism sexism asism
ableism
colonialism among others however there
are many other
ethical concerns that cannot be
associated with computing and ai systems
that have not surfaced through this
process for example the cost system in
india needs to be understood from the
local history philosophy and ethics
similarly the concerns of many muslims
around the use of human-like robot
needs to be understood from islamic
philosophy and associated ethics
such ethical concerns are really voiced
in the discourse of ethical computing
and i want to shed some light on this
issue
let us try to understand this issue
better by two stories from bangladesh
the first one is taken from a recent
paper written by christensen and his
colleagues
they wrote about a weather prediction
technology that they deployed in rural
bangladesh to help the farmers
let me read a paragraph directly from
the paper
the village mosque lies at the center of
the village life metaphorically as well
as physically
it is the spiritual moral and religious
epicenter of the village
therefore it was a blow to the project
that the local imam
after consideration disallowed ngo
staffs
used the mosque ps system as a means of
to broadcast messages
the local imam did not approve of the
announcement of the messages such as
weather forecast and associated
agricultural advice
stemming from the service in his mosque
the reason given by the imam was
theological
only allah knows a field officer
assigned from the local ngo to the
village
comes every five days or so and was
hoping to continue some messages
and forecasts to the villagers using the
mosque
select messages on for example extreme
weather predictions such as doubt
or flooding that may be considered
important and even vital for the welfare
of the village
and the india officer was hoping in the
process to promote the service and the
work of the ngo
a few messages were miked in the mosque
to use the expression
of the ng officer before the practice
was discontinued
now so as we can see here the local
community believes that only the god can
predict the future and any attempt to do
so by humans or technology
is considered challenging the god and
hence unethical according to their faith
the ethical concern of local villagers
was coming from an ethical standpoint
that is hardly taken seriously in ethics
and ai
on ethics and computing research if we
take
and take it further deeper uh meaning of
this ethics and computing or ethics and
ai
is built on a secular and imperative
philosophy
that is not aligned with the spiritual
nature of ethics in many faith-based
communities around the world
the second story is coming from an
ongoing project
by my student mohammed rifat rashid
jaman who has been studying the use of
social media by the faith-based
communities in bangladesh especially
the practicing muslims there in this
project we have been
studying why many practicing muslims
were not using modern online social
media like facebook
so this is what rifat wrote in his field
not in
february 2020. in our field work we
found religious muslim people were not
using facebook
we asked them why one of them explained
they do not like the ai algorithm of
facebook
we wanted to know more he said it is
very unpredictable for him he does not
know what will come
next to his new street what if he ends
up seeing or reading something that he
is not supposed to do
this uncertainty make him avoid using
facebook
or any other social media now as we can
see
many members of this practicing muslim
community are not comfortable with the
uncertainty of what can come to their
news feed
we note again that such ethical concerns
are
often not discussed in the western
discourse about ethics and ai or ethics
and computing
these and many other stories from our
fieldwork and that each body of work in
political philosophy anthropology social
sciences and theology
helped us understand why the idea of a
generalized and ubiquitous ethics
is both wrong and problematic more
importantly
taking an ethical standard from one
context and applying that on another
context
is a classical mechanism of silencing
people this kind of imposition of
foreign ethics was a common tendency in
colonial period
as evidence in the history as a result
many knowledges and practices of the
people of the colonized lands
were called illegitimate unethical or
substandard
this is why a turn to the idea of
justification that underpins the voice
of marginalized population is important
building on the definition of justice
given by nobel laureate indian economist
and philosopher amarthusain we define
justification both as an instrumental
and constitutive mechanism that
validates one action based on their
social and communal rights and their
reason for achieving freedom
so now we ask how can we design to be
just
for a traditional community in the rest
of my presentation i will describe three
stories from our ongoing project in
rural bangladesh to highlight three
important aspects of ethical design
with the local communities which are
often missing the design of competing
system
missing in the in the traditional
computing systems
especially in ai systems three these
three aspects are ecology
identity and full this project is being
led by my collaborator sheriff sultana
was born and raised in jaishow and
bangladesh where the field side is
she is currently a phd student at the
information science department of
cornell university
and also a facebook fellow the last few
years we have been
studying how people in six villages in
general joshua which is a district in
southwest bangladesh
interact with modern science and
computer technologies and how those
impact their well-being practices
in the three years we have documented
more than 50 cases of witchcraft
production of more than 25 kinds of
local art
and the local practices of baking and
gambling
during this time we conducted more than
300 interviews more than 20 focus group
discussions and taken more than 1000
photographs
at the same time we also conducted more
than 10 sessions of participatory design
with the villagers for solving local
problems we have been working with the
support of local ngos political leaders
local police and others
and some of the findings of our ongoing
study has already been published in
three of our recent publications in kai
and cscw
so if you are interested to know more
about our work i would recommend you
read the full versions of these papers
so let us first check some of the basic
information about the six villages that
will start is
it started 80 percent of the population
uh
in those villages are muslims around 19
are hindus and the rest are either
buddhist or christians
65 percent of the local population is
engaged in farming
so joshua is famous for producing rice
cotton lentils and jute
around 20 percent of the villagers are
fishermen and the rest are engaged in
various
other professions including pottery
living and
other small businesses the average
monthly income for the for a family is
5000 bangladeshi taka which is
equivalent to 59 us dollars
various different recent reports show
that these villages
are increasingly suffering from
landlessness overtake crimes
and migration to cities
over the course of our field work we
explored the villagers dependency on
witchcraft
for their well-being we found that they
considered the witches for various
troubles
which broadly include legal problems
natural disasters
family and financial crisis and health
problems
furthermore mental health patients are
almost always treated by the witches in
those villages
we found several reasons that influenced
the villagers to
choose witchcraft over other means of
support where the villagers mentioned
that
for hundreds of years their ancestors
held witchcraft in high regard for
spiritual well-being
we heard of frightening stories of the
local means where
various strange and extra human entities
known as
gene food evil spirits etc attempt to
harm
mankind by taking control over their
minds
pairs of supernatural entities were
found to be widespread among the
villagers and connected to their
respective religious faiths a number of
villagers
shared similar stories from elders that
bad
that had been passed down for
generations they mentioned that these
entities are often
blamed for missile misfortunes troubles
and accidents
and we just are believed to be the
superior to normal human beings in
sensing and analyzing this context
and considered to be only people capable
of helping
the villagers also share their concerns
regarding the limitations of scientific
medical practices for challenging this
spiritual situation they believe that
the doctors of the medical counselors
hear the physical or physiological
problems on a surface level
but fail to deal with the underlying
causes
which is on the other hand are more
trusted than educated professionals
because
they gain deeper understanding of the
context using the spiritual lens
emphasizing prevention
uh in addition to treatment
now i give you a quick uh overview of
the typical witchcraft therapy
session to help you understand how
witchcraft connects health and
well-being
with deeper moral problems of the
community so that which
therapy starts with investigation
regardless of their clients problems
they often use
informal conversations to gain deep
insight into their
particular problem for instance during
our
observation at one witches place we
found
one woman who came to take help the
woman mentioned that she lost a
necklace at the conversation progressed
the witch directed the
discussion toward the women's family
household and recent encounters with
visitors
at one point the witch said i think your
sister-in-law has taken it
my understanding is that this laws will
lead the suspicion to the elder bride
and then
deteriorate the relationship which will
benefit the sister in law the most
as this conversation progressed the
witch suggested activities that would
improve the relationship between the two
brides
the witch concluded with the message
that even if the necklace does not come
back to the woman
she will get something much more
precious which is mental peace
as we can see here the solution of the
loss of necklace was not limited to
getting back the necklace
but it addressed the problem of jealousy
between the brides
next the second step of witchcraft is
explanation
and prediction in this step the witches
explain the cause of a misfortune by
connecting them to supernatural powers
drawing upon their own explanations the
witches also make predictions
in this state the witch explains why
some misfortune happened to the client
most often that not the reason is anger
of the god which occurred because some
immoral activities either conducted by
their client or their relatives
in the fourth step of the witchcraft the
witches connect their own explanation to
their traditional
uh religions using some complex formula
this is important for the witchcraft not
to go against the existing beliefs
and maintain a harmony with the
community
here we remind you that the most popular
traditional beliefs in our field was
islam and hinduism as a result
there were two major tracts of
witchcraft prescriptions in this system
one was allah which was connected to
islam and the second one was kali mantra
which was
connected to hindu religion
and in the final step the witches give
the client material products to use and
tell them
the rules of how to use them the easiest
solutions are dua or mantra
or tabis or kriya so it is important to
note that these materials
are local and they contain text from
traditional religions
although using them in a way that was
not advised by those religions
this is in fact a very clear
demonstration of how the witches embed
the religious ethics
in the environment and the society here
the role of the witchcraft is not to
challenge the modern medical science
nor the religion but work with both of
them
their main role is to tie them together
in a way that the villagers moral
commitment to the environment and the
society becomes
stronger the witchcraft practices take
the problem from its modern scientific
formulation to a spiritual level
where they invade a problem in the
society and finds its root in morality
in these villages which are considered
intelligent people
and as we can see their intelligence is
rooted in holding the ethics of the
community by
attaching the villagers to their
environment and society
so at the same time the witches
also utilize their power to fight
various social norms including misogyny
radical religious rules health related
stigmas and tables
for example we noted at least seven
cases where the witches acting as the
marriage counselors
engaged in female female members of the
union councils and the police to
save female clients from their in-laws
who had tortured and starved them
demanded dowry etc
these incidents highlight how witches
justify their work by local value system
and in parallel work toward the freedom
of the villagers we find this aligned
with the definition of justice that
amarthu-san was
has given in his work
so now if we reflect on this on this
particular study we see that the rural
understanding of intelligence is
different from what we often think as
intelligence in the modern scientific
world
intelligence is rooted in holding the
ethical base of a society
and serving the community and nature
according to this real belief
and ethics in a society goes beyond
individuals benefit and the focus is
always on the ecological understanding
of well-being
next we turn to another important aspect
of
rural ethics in bangladesh that sets it
apart from
some common practices of data and
visualization in computer science and ei
we focus on the visual art practices in
rural bangladesh
and through this we saw we show how the
ethics in handling data
is different in rural bangladesh from
that in western scientific communities
in modern visualization practice the
meaning of a data that is encoded in the
presentation
is not affected by the medium for
example in the images on the right side
of the slide
we see snapshot of uh of
institutions funding research training
and clinical services
in 2018 on the top one the user is
watching the publicly available
electronic copy of the report opened in
their browser
in the bottom one another user is
watching the same portion of the report
on their mobile phone and both of the
users are expected to arrive at a
similar understanding of the information
here we would like to note that two
characteristics of modern data
visualizations practices
one data is not connected to any
particular material
and data is not connected to the people
who created the data
hence the practice of data collection
and visualization does not have the
ethical accountability to the people who
are affected by them
this is where the traditional data
visualization practices are different
here we will focus on two kinds of
visual art practices in rural bangladesh
to explain these differences
first the design of nakshikata this is a
type of embroidered quilt nakshikata is
a centuries old tradition in bengal
region
the basic materials used a great and old
globe
the colorful patterns and designs that
are embroidered resulted in the name of
nokshikata
which was derived from the bengali word
naksha which refers to artistic patterns
the early cutters had white background
accented with red blue black
embroidery lighter yellow green pink and
other colors also
included often comes with the theme
such thing includes micrological stories
renowned local
history and religious events the types
of stitches motives and ceiling of the
border of the nakshikata
have very situated meanings the meaning
and the interpretation of these motifs
might change depending on where it was
designed
and the second form of visual art that
we started was hindu idols or murthy
it is a general term for an image statue
or idol
of our deity or mortal hindu culture
in hindu temples it is a symbolic icon a
muti is itself not a god
in hinduism but it is a shape embodiment
and manifestation of a deity
so uh the murthy is typically made by
a carving stone woodworking metal
casting or through pottery
ancient era describing their proper
portions and
all these positions and gestures and in
the religious context they are found you
know in hindu temples or in different
festivals so making idols is a strictly
cost based profession
ideally the pal families practice this
craftsmanship and generally train their
male children for years at home
and at local local accurate tigers
so now in we will highlight some of the
distinct features of these two forms of
visual art in rural bangladesh that will
distinguish them from modern data
visualization practices
so first of all is this abstraction
one key element of the communicating
data in modern science both digitally
and in analog form
is the use of abstract marks like points
lines
bars curves or squares in some cases
single marks can represent collections
or even entire
data set for example a sim single bar
can represent the number of people
amount of annual income or the frequency
of range
in different graphs however that is
really the case for rural visualization
practice
the visual designers we've studied used
representation that were as close as
possible to the meaning
that they intended to convey avoiding a
high level of abstraction
for example goddess lakshmi there is a
lot full of wealth
generally the idol makers pay a lot of
money to show that
when you ask them if it is if it's
possible to replace that pot of money
with another mundane object
and convey the same message which could
be paper money
or you know like a bank check for
example linker in our focus group
discussion laughed at the idea and
explained
the part is not only about the money or
cash flow it's about the wealth that
will come
and sustain like the way the port holds
the wealth
in it ensuring the sustainability bank
checks might just fly out
right so that's the materiality
and the concreteness of the data is very
important there
the second point is that storytellers
provenance
national media often focuses on the
scalability and reproducibility does the
convention that are almost universal
among users digital system this is why
for a modern visualization practice it
is often unimportant to know about the
artist
and their perspective the artist often
has very little to say and in some cases
making the artist invisible means a
better visualization
however this is not true in rural
visualization practices in bangladesh
but it is very important to know about
the artists and their perspective to
understand visual art
for example the nakshikata that we can
see here
now uh contains a year's oath of
significant events as explained by a
housewife
the participant informed us that the er
would look different in someone else's
nakshikata since the relative
significance of the events
shape and the size of the object and
design sensibility
would vary percent comparison to person
she said
my great grandmother mapped all the
significant events happened that year
my cousin has another one that has made
my great-grandmother sister-in-law who
lived in the same house
that one had a bull and had a bull and
circus on it you know everyone's here
is different and their choice of motives
are also different
you might need to ask and verify what it
is about
this rural visualization practices data
cannot be separated from the story and
the story cannot be separated from the
storyteller
so in summary the in rural bangladesh
working with data makes one accountable
to their history and culture nature and
community and their
faith data cannot be separated from the
materials and social context
also data should be understood through
the lens of the storyteller
thus the for the rural people in
bangladesh ethics in data is embedded in
holding their
communal identity and moral values and
it is deeply situated in
local material culture
finally we turn to the question of hope
and lack and for this we investigate the
betting and
gambling practices in rural bangladesh
so the sports wedding is an activity of
predicting sports results and
placing a wizard on on the outcome
in neural bangladesh it is very common
for the villagers to betting on the
sports like cricket and football
in modern scientific world statistics is
widely used
to make prediction games and
we and people often use different
software for certain predictions
um in rural bangladesh we also saw that
villagers were using different
prediction software to see which team
is predicted to win however we found
that their final decision
was often different from what the
software was suggesting
this is where we found a clear
difference between
the statistical probability as we
understand in scientific practices and
what they mean by the hope so there are
different kinds
of baiting practices we found in the in
the field
uh positing one is which one is more
outdoor one played by
mean and the thorn was uh was also an
outdoor one but it was also mediated by
some other person and the khari is an
indoor waiting practices
in all forms of baiting we found that
the villagers relied
less on the statistical probability
their decision was mostly made by the
cultural values that they hold
for example they often label some people
as inaudible in local language
and their decision would often depend on
the decision of those in auspicious
people meaning that they would always
bet
the opposite to what that people take
for example in this board you see that
they
this on this inauspicious people they
were trying to find out what they would
be waiting for and they would go
exactly opposite to that besides such
superstitions
we also found that the decision was also
shaped by their religious or national
identities
this was evident when there was a
cricket match between pakistan and india
since pakistan was a muslim majority
country we found that most muslim
villagers in the in
in those in our field they were waiting
for pakistan although
the software was saying that india was
going to win
we saw similarly that you know when
there was a match against
bangladesh where bangladesh was playing
although the software was saying that
bangladesh was
going to lose they were supporting
bangladesh i want to highlight here that
their betting decisions were not only
coming from an
ethical obligation to their country
religion or culture but they really
believed that their faith would make the
supported team win
so here their prediction of future was
not shaped by the past data but a hope
for the future that is shaped by the
ethical
standpoint next we would also
do different kinds of they would also do
different kinds of calculations for
predicting the wind that are different
from
what we do in a statistical software for
example
if some of them failed in three
consecutive cases while begging for a
team
that they're ethically right to support
they believe that they are surely going
to win the fourth time
and it is important to note that this is
very much different from what we do
in modern machine learning and
scientific practices if
if if configured three or four times our
algorithm gives us a wrong result we
usually
change the algorithm or we take a
different decision but for them
the more they feel the closer they think
they are at
they are from the winning
so as we can see there are fundamental
differences between the western notion
of hope and rural traditional
understanding of hope in bangladesh
hope in rural bangladesh is not created
by past data or empirical evidence but
from an ethical standpoint uh secondly
modern scientific data-driven models
seldom involve cultural values that are
hard to quantify they function fully in
global south
uh where the ethics of hope here relies
on luck
which is hard to calculate using any
statistical mechanism
this is where faith and ethics become
important there
so what is intelligence as we can see
intelligence in traditional bangladeshi
community is defined by ethics
ecology communal values hope and
identity
its data qualities is quite different
from the modern western definition of
intelligence
which stands on scientific rationality
generalizability and probability
so if it's not a kind of intelligence in
traditional bangladesh but
ethics is an essential element of any
intelligence theory
we come back the question of whose
ethics now
let's go back to the original question
of voice
as we could see in our project that this
witchcraft and modern scientific
approaches are not universally practiced
and appreciated
in today's world while the majority of
the western world appreciates the modern
scientific understanding of
health and well-being for example many
other places in the world
they have different other perspectives
traditional healing witchcraft sorcery
and local practices are still prevalent
in those places in asia africa and latin
america millions of people
um in those places depend on those
faith-based practices
and we cannot just impose our ethical
understanding
on them and this particular issue is
also connected to the colonial history
of science and technology
for example across the history of the
colonization
and cultural imperialism traditional
medical practices were ignored as
sidelined
and now as computers computing devices
have become ubiquitous many hsa
researchers are now taking the
advantages of competing to spread this
pure ethical understanding of well-being
to the people who
who are coming from a different ethical
perspectives and this is where we find
it problematic
we also saw in the creation collection
and use of data
uh we have a strong ethical implication
in the traditional societies and they
cannot be thought without considering
the history and identity of the people
of those communities
so our study on traditional data
visualization practices show how the
rural bangladeshi communities have a
long and rich tradition of storytelling
and communicating information that is
strongly connected to the local art
culture people in history
and we cannot separate that from an
abstract level data representation which
is often practiced in the western world
and finally intelligence is being
hopeful
our study on baiting practices show that
there are fundamental difference between
the western notion of rationality and
the rural traditional rationality in
bangladesh
in many cases the western society is
individualized and secular
the good is often defined by personal
and individual benefit also the
traditional concept of luck is different
from probability
as defined in the literature of data
science and data driven decision making
while there is a trend in ai machine
learning and smart technology supported
world
you quantify and predict the future for
many people living in the traditional
societies in the global south future
largely depends on their luck and luck
is controlled by the god
so being ethical is the way to become
successful in future
not counting your past so we argue that
to sustain the voice of local
communities in north western societies
the current models of ai are not
sufficient the discussion and ethics in
ei should not only centered on the
western notion of ethics
we should get rid of a universal and
generalized form of intelligence and
localized and situated ethical practices
should consider local faith best
practices local historians and local
homes
so in order to have the voice of the
marginalized groups
in over company and over computing
platforms we need to make sure
that they have easy and equal access to
computing they have the necessary
autonomy
and freedom to express their rightful
concerns and their voice is not
suppressed by imposing a foreign
standard of ethics
building on my framework of voice my
team and i are now working on a few
projects to support and strengthen the
voice of marginalized communities
definitely ethics and ai in the global
south is
one of the main projects that we are
working on and these are the questions
that we are asking which
uh i explained briefly uh
and then uh we are also uh taking this
to
understand what it means by safe
computing here we are asking what is the
privacy and security from the global
health perspective how can we
you know address the problems of sexual
harassment misinformation
and environmental justice uh if we
consider the secreted ethics of the
global south
and we are still building on the idea of
participatory design and adversarial
learning in those projects
so as i'm working on these projects i
want to
thank all the funding agencies and
institutions for supporting uh for our
work
and they include insarcia hr shark nih
google microsoft research
samsung provide cornell university
and i also want to thank all my
colleagues and collaborators who have
been helping me advise this
uh this project forward um here are the
names of only a few of them and
definitely i want to thank my wonderful
research group artists at university of
toronto
so thank you all for patiently hearing
my talk i
would be delighted to hear your feedback
comments and questions now
also please feel free to reach out to me
at this email address if you have more
parts to share with me
thank you excellent thank you for
sharing the talk with us
so i will kick one off and then
we can go from there so i hear a tension
in your um in your presentation
between trying to avoid colonial
impulses
with with our ethics um but also
uh dealing with cultural relativism
right where
there's if you completely let go of any
sort of notion of universal human rights
then you're also going to be dealing
with you know you you yourself called
out
behaviors that were for example harmful
to women right which
may be totally reasonable within the the
local communities ethical framework
but one that it at least my sense was
implicit implicitly you were critiquing
so i wanted to sort of draw that tension
out and
ask you how you recommend we navigate it
both at a sort of a high level then
maybe specifically within one of the
projects you want to do how are you
going to
deal with that yeah no that's that's a
that's a fascinating question that's
actually a very important question
and the answer is actually very context
specific there is no like a universal
answer to this question
so there are a couple of things that we
need to understand here
is that there there there are definitely
some universal idea of what is good and
what is bad and there are like
levels that we try to maintain in the in
the societies
but we also uh believe that this
community the traditional communities
where this ethical standards
emerge from they also have their own way
of protect
this and these rights so uh and
in in different traditional communities
if we really believe that
there needs to be a social change the
social sense should come from within
so we need to work with them it's not
like we impose our ethics uh
on them so um i i can give you one
example especially with this um
with this uh questions of women's
freedom so we have been working with
um muslim islamic feminists for
last couple of years so who are still
working with this uh with the
empowerment of women
but being within this islamic framework
so you do not fight against islam for
making this you know or helping them to
get empowerment and there are wonderful
examples of
muslim women who actually have done that
and so
we want to work with them to bring those
changes in their communities
but it i guess like more of a process
question uh
that like how we work with the community
and each of these communities they have
their definitely these are not
monolithic communities
they also have internal tensions so
there we have this opportunity
to work with the the marginalized boys
within the community for example women
are often silenced in
in many traditional religious
communities
so why don't we work with them and move
it forward
but as i said it's a it's um
not all i mean it's very hard to
universalize
this thing is very context-specific
thanks panelists this is a good moment
if you any of you'd like to jump in
this talk was fascinating to me i i
learned a lot
um there's so much um
to to study and learn about cultures
like this
i'm wondering about um since um
this is a heterogeneous society that you
talked about
with muslims hindus and miscellaneous
others um how much
do they mix how how much do they respect
each other
and i'm sort of wondering if technology
can be one of those
others that kind of mix in like if
there are indigenous visualizations that
they understand
but um you know a computer thing
gives them this different visualization
can they understand it sort of the way
they understand those weirdo
hindus over there or something like that
well that that's again
like a really great question so now you
know if we
look at the history of this religions in
these communities we found that
um like islam also came a few hundred
years ago
to these communities like hinduism
probably came
a few you know like like 1 000 years ago
there
but these were like the some traditional
communities
they learned this um this religion their
religious practices
but they have like very strong cultural
practices which they consider their
identity
so religion is kind of like a
proper thing on the top of that but
beneath that there they consider
themselves equal and which is very
important
because when we were starting this um
witchcraft and
we just they were focusing on that they
were saying
that yes you can practice you know your
islam or hinduism whatever religion that
you practice but your community wants
mutual respect
these are more important so they were
then coming up with interpretations
of how you know if if they find that
some
uh some version some interpretation of a
religious text is uh
is you know driving them against one
another they are coming up with a
with an interpretation that kind of
negotiates them so the role of the
witches
and that's the intelligence that they
say is to find the deeper meaning and
the deeper meaning is that you don't
fight with each other
essentially but they are so there's no
like a
high level moral uh i mean
that the service that they give to the
community they so that they become
respectful to each other they become
respectful to environment the nature the
animals
so they try to hold them together and
anything which is coming externally they
kind of try to resist there
so for that what we found like
technology in itself is uh
they don't take that as a problematic in
which i know like you know
and many uh scholars they say like well
you know we don't believe
so they don't have you know uh any
problem let's say for
in terms of technology they're using
mobile phones computers and
you know like uh televisions what they
do not like is when uh these
technologies
tell them what is good and what is bad
what they need to do
so they they kind of like lose their
authority
so an ngo person comes and they you know
use this machine and they are telling
you
that tomorrow it will rain now you do
this they don't like that
they say well our god knows and you
cannot take that away from us so
it's a it's the day that the tension is
there it's not like you know the
technology itself
so the values that the authority that
technology brings with it
and which kind of like comes from an
idea even
if you're in the field you'll understand
that you know the scientists go there in
a
from a level they say well we understand
this because we are soil scientists we
know how soil work
and they say we have been you know uh
doing agriculture in this land for
thousands of years what if you so that
is the tension that
you know we found more problematic there
wonderful talk absolutely i'm with terry
on that
i just wow i just i said to my husband
early on i love this guy
so um i wonder if you could
um talk a little bit more about this
um experience where the ngo
basically created something that wasn't
wanted
or you couldn't didn't fit into the
culture
and do you feel like had they done
a better job of truly understanding
if they would not have done that or what
what do you think
it's a good question and susan i know
like you you know about the situation
here
most of these ngos are actually funded
by foreign
you know like money and this um the
funders often want
scientific and data and you know like
results and deport
so i i don't blame the ngos uh
months though if you don't put ai and
machine learning in your proposal even
for the ngos it's very hard to get
you know i'm saying the truth so we also
understand and many of these ngo people
they're local people they know that even
going there
they are telling us you talk to them and
they will not like it but why are you
doing this but they
that's that's you know they need money
so it's not that they don't understand
this
but um you know it's that also the age
of injurization
in that part of the world injury is also
a way they earn money
uh but i think uh if we kind of like
create a bit of like a local voice and
resistance uh
against it then that will be you know
helpful
it's not against machine learning it's a
very wrong very wrong interpretation
they are not against the technology but
don't take it away from the local people
they are also intel how can we help the
local leaders
so that they can hold this be the right
way to go
right right so can you i'm sorry to
follow up though
do you have any suggestions as to how we
can get that
mentality into the funders minds
so they kind of get it and they
understand it
where is that a losing battle no no so
here is here is one um here here is
uh one thing that we are working on a
lot of times even you know
in the in this machine learning world
when you will find the
biased output you will hear people
saying this problem is with the data
because there wasn't enough data or the
data was mislabeled
and it comes from an understanding that
well if we
had a lot of data from those people that
be you know like
the scenario will be changed but the
problem is that
the history in that part of the world
you
the scientific the science people do not
take that even in the his the methods of
history because
those histories are you know like the
oral history or they're in the in
you know in some part of that it's kind
of like a mythological
there is a way how you understand or
interpret me that is not taken seriously
in data science because data science is
more you know like an
empiricistic one so if we can establish
their history and there it is at the you
know
strong point then we can we can put that
before these funders
saying that well what they're saying is
also coming from an evidence
you cannot just throw it away it's you
know when they say
uh you know a devil will come it's
probably not a devil we need to
understand what they are talking about
and if we take this seriously you
understand that they are actually
you know talking about something which
actually happened in that land
and which is important before you design
something for that
so that is something we're trying to now
work on how we can make a
voice out of this data
which now scientists do not take
seriously and
can that be a way of um reading their
voice so it is now
being done in both ways we are also
working with the
local um uh you know like youth groups
for
uh for you know like teaching at this to
the
to the to the ngo workers or others who
are coming in and also with the
with the with the people who are kind of
like trying to help them from our side
to learn this this culture i think
it's both of these are important
i'd love to close with a student
question based on uh your
research what concretely do you think
that the big tech companies like
facebook should do
so that they can be more catered toward
you know local populations
it's uh okay so
this is a good question and this is also
a hard question for me to answer
um but i think if uh one
good thing that i liked about facebook
is their
idea of making connections and i think
that is also
that this is one thing that we also
found that the
the traditional people they value but
the connection
has to be meaningful connection so i
think
if facebook really you know like um
wants to
to focus on their idea their philosophy
of connection
they need to work with these people and
try to understand who they want to get
connected to
and what kind of message they want to uh
you know like spread or want to
tell other people their stories so it
may come from
the modalities of the information and
the way they are treated in the
in the community right now what we are
seeing is that when traditional
people in the traditional communities
when they talk in the
uh in the you know like a public forum
they are often mocked ridiculed
and their challenge like where is your
evidence you know we
have created um digital space which is
anytime from all kind of you know like a
faith you
you cannot talk about that it has to be
very data driven and
you know like uh this uh imperative way
of talking about this and that is
silencing them
so people might want to create a space
like for facebook or these big companies
that are respectful
to um their you know like designed
within the
uh with their values
all right let's close it here thank you
so much for joining us
uh we will see you all soon and some of
the folks in the group will have a
chance to chat with you earlier today
or later today uh thanks for for ending
our seminar for the quarter we are
we're we're very grateful that you that
you joined us i'll see you all soon